oh no it's no no no wow
I hope my wife has dinner ready for once
in my life well why is traffic so
trafficking Oh can't even drive in this
town anymore
the Petersons finally mowed their lawn
took about a half a summer now maybe
their kid will get a haircut and
everything will be fine
what the hell is this thing
well where am I gonna Park now what is
this
what are you waving at so about what the
hell is that mean who are you take it
down pull your pants up I think what was
happening I've got a naked girl my son
pants up and you tell me to calm down
and tell me what can we got here yeah I
can explain I swear all right no need to
explain
honey just go to your room finish your
homework okay I'll finish all right what
are you doing what is she so upset I
know okay she's scared
so what is this a madhouse Kevin what's
going on here you can wear these these
are so much Susan's leftover clothes and
everything's gonna be amazing so don't
worry about my husband he is a bit of a
psycho everyone knows it everyone but
he'll calm down is everybody else moving
there is it just you what is this some
kind of joke here I'm not laughing
I know okay it's not a joke she's she's
from the video game uh uh uh the Simmons
house
she's from a video game that's what
we're saying now that's what you're
that's why I'm married
somebody's telling me somebody's
existing from video games what one next
Mario that is Luigi this one's gonna
live here she's gonna have to find a job
video game character or not we need some
money in here I can't afford these
people should work with you yeah that'll
be the day work with me yeah all right
let's get this going
do you know how to take phone calls
there you go I win hire Shinzon know how
to speak to the people I would be
talking to I work for a living I don't
have Candyland dreams like you two
idiots I think I want to die
my family's nuts and a video game
character I've lost my appetite that's
for sure please eat that chicken No you
know how I get when somebody doesn't
finish their meal
hey guys I hope you enjoyed today's
episode of cinemates world
I loved filming it my friends were
cracking me out throughout it now I have
a question for you if you have any ideas
of what you want to see Samantha do any
sort of adventures write them in the
comments below and maybe you'll get a
episode for your idea thank you guys so
much for watching subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next Friday for
the next episode of cimmyt world bye
guys have a great weekend tji - the f